Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to job simulator.
BACON! whoo shit. Eh, it's probably still good
Is this hot? Oh shit... It's so realistic. It's bubbling.
I wonder what will happen if I - *munch* Whoa.
I didn't mean to do that!
I love it when my eggs are on fire. They call it "Eggs Benedick"
Job Bot: Now put your creations on the plate,
and you can ring the bell to send it out to the restaurant.
Mark: Oh, that would be much better than just setting it on the dirty counter top!
Job Bot: "Tea", the traditional human beverage -
Crumpets. Crumpets, crumpets, crumpets. Are these crumpets?
I don't know what British speak means!
*Mark gets drunk*
Corn, cookie, and pretzel soup. Naturally artificial.
Is it a never-ending loaf of bread?
Oooh my God it iiiiiis
Oh my God! It never ennnnnds!
French Bot: It is a 1984 vintage. Eh? I wish to have it prepared.
Mark: Ew!
It looks delicious! What happens if I put olive oil in a cup? Would you like that?
I mean you're French,
you wouldn't know the difference, huh?
*INTENSE MUSIC*
Waiter Bot: We got three bots out here to ordered the special...
Mark: I'm going to be exactly uncreative.
Sriracha on a potato...
How about corn Cob Sandwich? And a little garnish?
How about an irradiated cactus?
PewDiePie: The hell man?!
Mark: All right, you're welcome there buddy. Hope you're having a good day!
*elevator music*